you probably don't give your lamp much
thought when you switch it on but the
San Francisco design firm box clever
recently spent two years designing a
lamp that would suit their needs
perfectly we set out to do a lamp that
was really just about the light I'm sure
life it wasn't just about reading it
wasn't just about working next to a
computer it was about the versatility of
a workspace this desire for control over
light and movement would eventually give
rise to the faid task light the faid
task light will set you back 250 bucks
250 is way less than you're going to pay
for a lot of other designer lamps but
even more impressive in its price point
is how much versatility this thing packs
into it's simple sleek design but
designing something so simple required
countless hours of prototyping first
step we took was to take these two
pieces of material and then create a
dynamic hinge that could be set in any
position and we quickly realize that but
we needed more more distance here
between these two pieces to have more
movement so the next step we created a
different mock-up you can see a lot more
of their sliding in and out and smooth
adjustability the more distance we
created your the lamps form isn't the
only thing that's adjustable with the
push of a finger you can dim the lights
brightness or change its temperature
from cool to warm the interface
officially was a disk interface where
you would press and hold and turn on and
then you would rotate to get your
brightness level it's simple mechanics
and it's clean lines make the fade light
a beautifully conceived departure from
the springs and hinges and cables that
would define the task lights form factor
for close to 80 years the goal is always
to have that adaptability with
there's seamless motion and the fewest
amount of parts when we approach any
project the ideal is nothing nothing
except that except the function and
every step along the way was trying to
achieve that core idea